half a dozen states in the midwest are
cleaning up this morning after a rare
storm with a hundred mile an hour winds
that tore across hundreds of miles the
so-called ratio
packed the power of a hurricane a
thousand miles from any ocean
it caused significant damage across iowa
and parts of wisconsin
and illinois yesterday adriana diaz is
in chicago adriana
what's the damage there
good morning michelle but we're in the
neighborhood of rogers park on the north
side of chicago and the national weather
service
says a tornado passed through this
neighborhood and look at what it left
behind
there are downed trees on top of cars
all across this area
then as a tornado pushed east it
actually went over lake michigan which
is just a few blocks away
the weather moved it quickly it struck
fast and it tore through the midwest
in a matter of hours
the downpour moved into iowa monday
leaving hundreds of thousands without
power
officials issued travel advisories as
the storm downed trees
and blocked roads pummeled by the high
winds
a child's clubhouse started rolling like
a tumbleweed
there were people inside this hockey
arena when the roof was blown away
no one was hurt a des moines postal
worker also escaped injury
when his truck was crushed by a falling
tree
i heard a whistle i never heard a siren
but i think it was the wind whistling
because it was just blowing really hard
when the storm reached wisconsin
it uprooted trees and downed power lines
huge branches crashed into streets and
houses
one person said the winds came without
warning
i was hearing all these different sounds
i turned and looked out the window and
realized i was
it was a full frontal force of the storm
coming in
emergency crews worked to ride a semi
truck overturned on the highway
the storm also uprooted trees here in
chicago
and more than a hundred miles away in
moline illinois
three four blocks down they had a real
big tree down on a power line
there were some reports of injuries in
iowa where people were trapped in
buildings and inside cars
about a hundred miles west of here in
dixon illinois the national weather
service
said wind gusts topped 90 miles per hour
anthony wow some very dramatic pictures
adriana thank you